hello fellow geeks in this video we are
going to take a look at the xiaomi mi
watch light also known as the redmi
watch it's a simple smart watch with
activity tracking heart rate monitoring
sleep tracking and it also has its very
own built-in
gps just like its other products xiaomi
has gone for the minimalist package
design and it comes in a simple sleek
black box with a picture of the watch on
the front the specifications and some of
its main features at the back
xiaomi is known for his good quality for
its budget price
so it would be interesting to see how
their watches will do
in the box we get the watch itself a
small manual and its proprietary
charging dock with a usb type-a at one
end
it doesn't come with its own charging
plug
but you can connect the dock with a usb
plug or a portable charger to charge the
watch the charging dock itself is not
the magnetic type and rather you would
need to snap the watch to it to charge
the watch
in charging mode you can orient the
watch on the side and it turns into a
neat looking clock that you can set on
your table which is a nice feature
the user manual is quite simple and has
multiple languages it covers the basic
needs to set it up and how to navigate
through the menus
anyway it's not a complicated watch so
it's easy to figure out even without
using the manual
[Music]
the watch has a rectangular shape
with curved bezels
and it looks very nice and sporty
especially for such a low price
on the back we have the heart rate
sensor and the contact points for
charging
the overall material of the watch is
made out of a rubbery tpu material which
makes it very lightweight weighing only
34 grams
regarding sensors we have an
accelerometer for counting steps
a heart rate sensor for measuring heart
rate gyroscope for motion data an
electronic compass barometric pressure
sensor and an ambient light sensor
you also get gps and glonass satellite
positioning for fitness
tracking on the right side of the watch
is a push button which is mostly used to
turn on the display but it also works as
a back button
the bands are made of silicone and the
buckle is made of polycarbonate plastic
which is durable and doesn't feel
brittle
they are flexible and comfortable to
wear
and they have quick release pins to
easily change straps
the watch has a waterproof agm rating of
5 atmospheres and is also water
resistant to up to 50 meters in depth
for 10 minutes and suitable for low
velocity shallow water activities like
swimming or washing your hands
regarding battery life by default it can
last up to 9 days and depending on your
usage it could vary
in my test i had everything on the whole
time and the screen at 100 brightness
it lasted me about 8 days which is
pretty decent for a smart watch at this
price
setting up the watch is very easy
simply turn on the watch and scan the qr
code on the screen
on my iphone this sends me directly to
the xiaomi rear light app and the apple
app store
it is also compatible with android
phones
all we need to do now is to set up an
account and when that's done head over
to profile and add device
the watch should pop up by itself so all
we need to do is to select it and accept
the pairing and that's all there is to
it we can start using the watch
it's not a big watch so it sits nicely
on the wrist
the bands are very comfortable
the display will automatically switch on
when we turn the wrist and it's got a
1.4 inch display with a resolution of
320 by 320 pixels with a pixel density
of 323 ppi
it looks very good the fonts look sharp
and has good black levels
it's also got bluetooth 5 so i haven't
had any problems with the connection at
all on the main screen with the default
watch face we have all the necessary
information like time day date calorie
loss battery life heart rate and steps
taken
if you don't like this watch face you
can change it by holding on the screen
here's an analog one the sub-dials are
colored differently each of them showing
the corresponding data
here's another one with a nice orange
theme that shows both analog and digital
this is a simple analog watch face that
shows less information
you can also save and transfer watch
faces from the xiaomi red light app and
here's different watch faces to match
your style
gestures are also included in this watch
swiping down will bring you to the
recent notifications panel
swiping left and right will cycle
through widgets such as your last played
music heart rate monitor fitness tracker
and more
swiping up we'll show a quick toggle
settings menu where you can activate the
watch's flashlight mode
race to wake up a lock mode
do not disturb mode
a mode to leave your watch awake for 5
minutes
and a gear icon which will take us to
the watch settings
in the watch settings there are a few
settings that you've seen on the quick
toggle menu here you can select watch
face designs you can manually adjust
your screen brightness or just leave it
at auto adjust
and activate do not disturb mode
the nd mode can be set manually which is
very good
it's not always fun to get notifications
in the middle of the night so all
watches should have this function
you can also enable and disable heart
rate monitoring here
as well as additional functions like
setting the intervals to monitor your
heart rate
if you want to save some battery you can
deactivate the hard monitoring function
head to system settings you will find
the power off and reset functions
pressing the function button will bring
up the main menu it consists of all the
watches apps and functions my menu is
simple and it's not scrollable
and swiping it changes to the next page
unfortunately though you can't download
more apps to the watch
starting with the workout app this app
helps you to record particular workouts
such as running on the thread mill
outdoor running swimming and more
to start an activity we first get the
three seconds countdown timer so we can
get ready
in the activity panel we can see the
time spent heart rate distance
and amount of steps you have taken
you don't get any more information about
the activity so all we can do from here
is to pause it or finish it
a neat feature about this app is that
you can set your goals such as the
distance you would like to run
the amount of calories you would like to
lose
or the amount of time you want to spend
running next is the activity app which
shows a sudbury record of recent
activities
this is where you can also find
additional details about your summary
record like your heart rate and how
intense or light your workout was
you also have a stats app which shows a
summary of calories burnt steps taken
and times where you have spent standing
swiping out gives you even further
information and details including ideal
daily goals and activities throughout
the day
next we have the sleep app which shows
us a simple view of your sleep data
showing the night's deep sleep light
sleep and total sleep also have a
breathing app which is a meditative app
and we can choose between one to five
minutes as well as setting your
breathing speed this works the same way
as on some other watches with an
animation text and vibration prompts to
tell us when to breathe in and breathe
out
a good little guide for relaxing and
breathing the xiaomi watch light also
boasts outdoor apps such as an in-built
compass and a barimetric air pressure
app which is ideal for tracking and
camping
the music app is compatible with most
music players i've used tidal with no
hiccups it has basic remote functions
such as playing the next and previous
song
play and pause as well as controlling
your music volume
it also shows the title of the song
you're currently playing which makes it
convenient so you don't have to whip out
your phone all the time
it also has basic functions such as an
alarm mode where you can set multiple
alarms and have it repeat throughout the
days in a week
and with that you will only get a few
vibrations on your wrist you will notice
some lag especially when setting a timer
or an alarm so scrolling to get the
right numbers winds up being too laggy
which makes it difficult to get the
settings right
the alarm will repeat itself after 10
minutes just like a snooze button and
you can dismiss the alarm by pressing
the function button there's also a timer
mode which can be set from 1 2 3 and 5
minutes and you can also set your own
custom timer there's also a stopwatch
mode which allows you to start stop
resume pause and even has a lab function
the weather app has a simple ui that
shows the temperature and its current
weather
swiping down reveals the weekly forecast
we also have a notifications app
here we can see all of our notifications
coming through our phone
we can also see that when it comes to
scrolling there is a little bit of lag
and it can be quite annoying
when it comes to reading the
notifications the text is nice and clear
and you are able to scroll down to read
longer text however if the message is
too long
it is not possible to read the whole
message without taking out the phone
next let's give ourselves a phone call
and see what happens
the watch does not have an inbuilt mic
and so it only allows us to reject the
call
one feature that i like the most is the
find phone app which enables you to
search for your phone as long as it is
in bluetooth range
to find your phone tap the tab to search
function and your phone will
automatically beep
wait if you misplaced your phone
somewhere else
let's take a look at the xiaomi
watchlight phone app the ui and data are
easy to use and looks well thought out
and planned
you get a more detailed view of your
status such as your steps taken
calorie loss your workout history sleep
data heart monitoring and more
tapping into the workout panel you can
get an overview of your data and you're
able to monitor your location and
progress on the map this app is very
useful especially if you've forgotten to
bring your watch
tap onto profile you can check on the
devices setting it will show our watch
status
and the watch faces panel which you can
source for more watch faces
online you can download and save it
straight to your watch
and it takes about a minute or so and
the connection is steady
we also have a setting guide for ios
users and under app notifications we can
enable or disable notifications on the
device
we also have a user guide and a help
center to help you troubleshoot as well
as information on how to use the apps on
the watch under additional settings we
can manage and sort the widgets on the
watch receive weather updates check for
system updates
additional information about the device
as well as an unpair function
all in all this is a lightweight and
very sleek looking watch a full charge
gave me more than a full week of usage
with everything switched on and always
connected by bluetooth
the display is bright and vibrant with a
good resolution and for a cheap price it
looks more expensive than it is
it's a simple looking watch with a good
amount of features and gps
so the tracking data is useful and the
graphs and charts are nicely presented
in the phone app
the menu is simple and quick to navigate
and the apps in the watch are useful but
i wish we can add apps like carrot fit
and other apps that can be downloaded
if you are looking for a smartwatch for
daily use minimal design
and offers a lot of features for its
budget price this watch is for you or
can be used as a gift thank you for
watching this video if you haven't
already consider subscribing to our
channel and give us a like smash that
bell icon so you can stay updated to our
latest videos
until then this is zaki from geek
culture signing off adios
[Music]
you